[Music]
Godzilla fought two Titans in the first
movie the mut male and the female in
king of the monsters he fought only
gidora but a total of three times in GVK
he had two fights against Kong and then
one against Mecca Godzilla and now in
Godzilla Kong the new Empire he will be
quite busy and his battle will double in
number as well as the Titans he will
fight so here in this video we will tell
you guys what are the five Titans that
Godzilla will battle in the new movie
let's get to it the first Titan that
Godzilla will battle is the mysterious
araq nit Titan in Rome this here is
confirmed as per the trailer and the
added scene in the newly released first
trailer for Japan in the trailer in a
split scene you could see the spiky limb
of an unknown Titan crushing a
construction worker in the middle of the
streets in Rome and in the Japanese
trailer in the end a scene of Godzilla
in the Coliseum is shown which confirms
that he will indeed face off the IRA nit
Titan there in Rome and it will might
very well be Siller as per rumors and so
here in this fight he would kill it once
and for all since Silla had been acting
like a a renegade ever since kotm
and then again in Godzilla Dominion when
it was attacking ships when it should
have been away
hibernating the next Titan that will
face Godzilla's wrath will be Tiamat as
per a verifiable rumor she will be seen
making a layer out of a cabin beneath
the Greenland eyes the I sheet beneath
Greenland but just like in Dominion
where she was chased out of the top G's
old crib Godzilla will seek out this
layer as well for himself but this time
it will be in order for him to evolve as
to be able to fight a greater enemy
later in the movie now in Godzilla
Dominion the Big G was surprised
attacked by tiamut when he came to his
old resting place the fight was a real
struggle as Godzilla nearly was defeated
by the serpentine Dragon like Titan it
was only due to his termal vision was he
able to track the movements of tiamut
and drag her on land and defeat her here
in gxk he would face a similar fight but
it would not just be for a show of alpha
status it would be for a dire necessity
in order to absorb the Ping Hollow Earth
radiation for him to grow and evolve
into the pinkzilla form
yes yes Kong will also have another
short battle with Godzilla but it won't
be like that of GVK this battle will be
short and sweet it would not be a battle
for Supremacy or a battle for vengeance
but rather a confrontation that will end
in a peace deal between the two Titans
as you all know Godzilla and Kong after
the GVK made peace and went on their own
separate ways but it didn't mean that
they were friends this truth was
conditional as long as Kong sticks to
his hollow Earth and left Godzilla the
surf surf then there would be no beef
between the two but since Kong would
fight scar King and maybe even shimu
eventually fleeing for his life to the
surface again he would be confronted by
Godzilla again but something cool will
happen which I shall not reveal or spoil
that will convince or Force the two to
join forces again together in order to
deal with the greater world-ending
threats So Kong is the third Titan that
Godzilla will fight who is the fourth
one well Godzilla will most definitely
fight fight against the scar King as
well as the Director in a tweet said
that this new ape titan will be too big
for just one Titan to deal with meaning
that Kong and godzil will have to team
up against this new Hollow Earth Tyrant
there was a rumor that scaring was
defeated by Godzilla in the past and was
imprisoned by Godzilla inside the hollow
Earth but that might just very well be a
rumor anyway since carar King is the
main villain of the show and he would in
the first half of the movie defeat Kong
therefore it is only logical that he
will have to fight with Godzilla 2 if
not on a one-on-one face off then
definitely attack team with him and
shimu against the top G and the Big K
meaning Kong and lastly of course
Godzilla will fight the ancient shimu
Titan in a battle that will Define the
true Apex Titans ship the true Alpha of
the planet or it could just be the same
fight that includes Kong and scaring
this fight will mirror the Boston battle
in kotm where gods fought Gora while
Mothra battles rod down for Air
Supremacy so in the final battle at
least Godzilla will get his ass whooped
and also give an ass whooping to shimu
and scaring as well although I might add
that Godzilla might fight shimu quite
early on in the movie as well and
therefore this loss would force him to
go evolve in T's Greenland ice cave but
that's just what I think also K will
have his own separate battles against
the W dogs those wolf Titans as well as
with the other Kongs and there will also
be suko the mini Kong fighting against
some other Titan and also an appearance
of
Doug now if you like this video then
check this other one as well and do
check out our channel for other monster
us content we might just have things
that you haven't seen before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video take care fam